[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur le
plateau de dimanche
en politique le titre de l'émission
d'aujourd'hui c'est européenne
le grand chamboule tout aujourd'hui on
parle des européennes qui sont passés et
puis des municipales à venir le prochain
scrutin c'est en mars 2020 dans moins de
dix mois 4 avec a invité avec tout sur
ce plateau pour en débattre
tout d'abord anna maillard d'europe
écologie et les verts
elle était candidate sur la liste de
yannick jadot à elle n'a pas été élue au
parlement européen
face à elle jacques richard des ticos et
régional du rassemblement national qui
était aussi candidat et rennes pour ces
européennes pas et lui non plus damien
meslot le maire de belfort le maire des
républicains et puis eric alauzet député
de la république en marche du doubs est
également candidat à l'élection
municipale de l'année prochaine
n'oubliez pas vous pouvez commenter ce
débat grâce à twitter avec hashtag dit
mme paul fc comme dimanche en politique
franche comté alors pour planter le
décor voyons un petit peu déjà à rappel
des résultats de dimanche soit pour ces
élections européennes le rassemblement
national arrive en tête dans notre
région comme dans chacun des quatre
départements 26% sur la région la
république en marche prend la deuxième
place avec presque 20 %
à noter une spécificité régionale
l'écart est beaucoup plus important
entre le fn et la république en marche 1
point au niveau national 6 points chez
nous et puis c'est europe écologie les
verts qui monte sur la troisième marche
du podium avec presque 13% des voix les
républiques à occupe la quatrième place
avec un peu moins de 10% des suffrages
alors on va commencer ce tour de table
par l'un des grands partis vainqueurs
des élections de dimanche à savoir le
rassemblement national alors que jacques
richard des ti vaut donc vous avez un
peu perdu en pourcentage même si le
nombre de voir s'est maintenue est ce
que vous êtes quand même satisfait ou
vous avez un petit regret parce que vous
espériez peut-être faire mieux donc des
grandes villes et notamment à besançon
écoutez moi on est on est très content
de cette vie
voir qui est net qui n était sans bavure
26% au niveau de la franche comté c'est
c'est du jamais vu
c'est trois points de moins si c'est pas
du jamais vu parce que c'est trois
points de moins que il y a cinq ans vous
êtes leaf et 29 % il ya cinq ans alors
trois points demain c'est déjà une
victoire large sur le deuxième partie
qui est loin derrière nous cette fois-ci
l'écart est creusé sept c'est la fin
d'un c'est la fin de l'ambiguïté
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui on a c'est la
fin c'est la fin du clivage droite
gauche la droite est morte la gauche
aussi
très clairement on est dans un clivage
de nationaux et deux mondialistes
c'est ce que c'est l'enseignement de ce
parti ont propre nom en prenons
l'exemple de la droite si vous voulez
bien qu'ils n'aient qui n'assure fait
que sur des ambiguïtés la droite compte
qu'on entendait parler qui se réclamait
de valeur qu'elle sait qu'elle était en
valeur on n'en sait rien des gens qui on
lui demandera justement elle damien
meslot nos représentants de la droite
des républicains
anna maillard votre parti europe
ecologie les verts a créé la surprise
c'est le deuxième grand vainqueur de ces
élections
alors est ce que vous pensez qu'il ya eu
une prise de conscience de l'électorat
certainement tous les partis politiques
ont verdi plus ou moins leur discours
maintenant quand même votre problème
c'est qu'il va falloir concrétiser tout
ça oui tout à fait on est moi je
remercie beaucoup les électeurs qui nous
ont fait confiance et ceux qui nous le
ferons nous fera encore confiance par la
suite ce qu'on a un projet écologiste de
société un projet de société pour ce
mandat électoral du parlement européen
on a su convaincre
il faudra aussi montrer qu'on peut
proposer des projets écologistes hauteur
les mines à l'échelon des municipalités
des régions de l'état français mais on a
de l'expérience sur des municipalités
des régions des parlementaires qui vont
y en a plus et s pour ce mandat au
parlement au parlement français mais on
a des exemples concrets qu'on souhaite
appliquer pour montrer que l'écologie
politique
elle a sa place dans l'organisation
territoriale alors damien meslot comme
je le disais vous êtes le maire les
républicains de belfort
votre parti c'est le grand perdant de ce
scrutin emmanuel macron a fait en 2017
exploser le ps visiblement dimanche
c'était au tour en franche comté vous
avez quand même dix parlementaires sur
20 et vous n'avez pas vraiment réussi à
résister qu'est ce qui s'est passé
écoutez je crois que c'est clair c'est
un échec de la droite républicaine nous
avons perdu la moitié de nos goûts
je pense que c'est dû à plusieurs
phénomènes déjà un problème de
leadership nous avons un vrai problème
de leadership à la tête de votre parti
au pour conduire la liste à la tête de
notre à la tête de notre parti et nous
n'avons jamais nous n'avons jamais assez
réfléchi sur les causes des échecs
successifs que nous avons connue donc
tout est à reconstruire
je crois d'ailleurs que la donne je vous
interromps vous demander la démission de
monsieur wauquiez
comme je demande pas de démission
particulier l'un de vos proches qui
s'appelle yann bout car quel député avec
dix autres j'avais piqué vous en parler
allez-y voilà je pense que au delà de la
démission de telle ou telle chacun doit
tirer les enseignements je rappelle que
nicolas sarkozy avait fait 12 % aux
européennes
il a démissionné et quelques années plus
tard il est élu président de la
république européenne sont vraiment un
scrutin particulier mais il est clair
que la droite républicaine que d'une
crise et la tribune ont signé les onze
jeunes députés dont il ya nous car le
député du territoire de belfort est
intéressante parce que il faut tout
remettre sur la table et vous m'en direz
des nouvelles idées et des nouvelles
têtes
oui parce qu'on a un problème de
leadership non aussi un problème et
d'idées il faut clairement on peut pas
se limiter à parler de l'immigration des
frontières et ne pas aborder l'ensemble
des autres thèmes qui intéressent les
français donc on va finir ce tour de
table par le parti présidentiel à savoir
la république en marche
eric alauzet vous êtes député lrm du
doubs vous avez déjà annoncé votre
candidature pour la mairie de besançon
emmanuel macron a perdu son pari le
rassemblement national et devant donc sa
candidate nathalie l'oiseau c'est un
échec symbolique mais c'est quand même
un échec
visiblement même vous vous n'arrivez pas
à endiguer le rassemblement national ce
qui est un échec c'est effectivement les
scores du rassemblement national même
s'il est inférieur à ce score 10 à 5 ans
est très important trop important et je
peux évidemment pas me mets réjouir mais
je me satisfait quand même du vote
global de l'ensemble des partis
européens écologistes et pour moi ça
c'est une belle satisfaction
c'est une résistance en à son don à ce
qu'on attendait en france et en europe
une raz-de-marée des nationalistes ça ne
s'est pas produit et c'est plutôt ceux
du camp européen et non pas des
mondialistes
vous dit de celles et ceux qui pensent
que les problèmes mondiaux seraient
visiblement le les électeurs de des
républicains sont partis sur la
république en marche c'est quand même la
preuve que la politique de ce
gouvernement une puis deux ans et une
politique de droite je pense qu'ils
n'ont pas voulu partir sur le
rassemblement national et que la
politique qui est menée leur convient
sans doute savez vous savez éthique
monsieur vous savez que dans le même
policier que vous savez que dans ce
mouvement il y a des gens qui ont une
sensibilité de gauche comme c'est mon
cas gauche écologiste d'autres une
sensibilité de droite et c'est en partie
effectivement qui a une capacité
d'attraction sur les différents les
différents bon très bien on va passer
maintenant donc à la deuxième partie de
cette émission à savoir les élections
municipales
la prochaine échéance c'est dans dix
mois on sait bien et damien meslot l'a
évoqué à demi mots ces deux scrutins
n'ont rien à voir
aux européennes ont dit que l'électeur
quelquefois se défoulent parce qu'ils
risquent rien les municipales c'est
autre chose d'ailleurs les français ont
énormément d'affection pour l'heure mais
c'est le personnage politique en qui ils
ont le plus confiance
malgré ces précautions oratoires quelles
perspectives pour vont nous envisager un
ajustement amer sur ce plateau
donc c'est damien meslot mairie pardon
de oui vous vous êtes maire de tressan
dans moi j'ai juste le maire de la
deuxième ville la plus importante de
franche comté on vous donnera la parole
après qu'on puisse y chante pas très
tendance et combien d'habitants en cinq
à huit ans 35 habitants cinquante mille
belges est gratuite voilà donc on va
commencer avec vous damien meslot
quand on voit que les républicains aussi
peu sur votre ville est ce que vous vous
ai dit ouh là là l'année prochaine il
représente pas je me sauve en courant
écoutez choix déjà que pour le moment à
belfort le principal sujet c'est pas de
savoir qui va être candidat ou pas aux
municipales c'est de savoir comment on
traite le problème du plan social de
general electric mille emplois supprimés
on en a assez de cette semaine a bien
sûr c'est cela moi en tant que mère ma
principale préoccupation
et je ne suis absolument pas dans
l'après aux clients vous ironisez les
chaînes me suis dit ceci dit je n'ai pas
pris ma décision
ceci dit quand on prend le score des
républicains qui est un petit peu plus
élevé que le score national puisque nous
faisons 10,6 à belfort c'est pas
glorieux mais c'est quand même deux
points j'allais dire
points deux de mieux que haut niveau et
dans le département du territoire de
belfort vous avez tous les postes ou
presque oui vous savez le département la
ville à metz de députés sur deux cette
apps est un vote national maintenant sur
les élections municipales
ce seront des sujets municipaux qui
seront en cause et pas du tout les mêmes
sujets qu'au niveau qu'au niveau
national
et puis vous savez nous à belfort pour
le moment on est vraiment complètement
investi dans le problème de general
electric et les municipales c'est
vraiment pas notre préoccupation
première
alors monsieur richard des ti donc vous
vous êtes maire de tressan dans 35
habitants vous représentez l'année
prochaine évidemment mais je me dirais
alors je voulais voir moi je voulais
vous dire moi j'ai pas de mépris pour
les pour les 35 habitants de la commune
bon monsieur damien meslot 50000
habitants irak 35 chez moi j'essaye de
faire mon travail et surtout de ne pas
les tromper ni les dupes et moi je
voudrais rappeler que monsieur damien
meslot pour parler d' ambiguïté de la
suite de ce scrutin européen a voté là
c'est la cession de 2 des actifs
d'alstom à general electric et de la
branche turbines je pense que je rêvais
à quel moment monsieur richard des ti en
tant que député mais non il n'y a pas eu
de vote là dessus quand tout le monde
est à vous
on ne ne fait pas de vote vous vous êtes
voyeuse et des positions longues et vous
êtes position de la chine sur le
problème
monsieur englobant nationale ces besoins
des cio est énorme et non en disant plus
la ficelle est grosse
mieux ça passe mais s'il vient le super
solo vous avez été pour cette session il
y avait les traités pour cette session
moi je suis aujourd'hui je vais aller
payer les 3 l et r regarder la partie
d'alstom au sein d' intérêts français et
je rappelle que nicolas sarkozy
lorsqu'il était au pouvoir a fait
prendre 21% du capital d'alstom pour
sauver alstom
j'aurais bien aimé que le gouvernement
précédent vous avez surnommée la dame
vous raconter gallows et juste est ce
que vous voulez dire venez en 30
secondes sur general electric et après
on passe vraiment au municipal pour moi
ya deux sujets il ya le sujet immédiat
je comprends les préoccupations de mains
du maire de belfort il en première ligne
il ya des salariés qui vont peut-être
perdre leur emploi avec des familles
derrière donc faire le maximum pour
garder le maximum de personnes à
l'intérieur de l'entreprise
le ministre le maire vient la semaine
prochaine pour avec les syndicats
comment faire au mieux et reclasser le
plus possible les gens et apprennent de
long terme qui est celui de la
diversification et la cooptation de
l'entreprise
les centrales au gaz et que le gast une
énergie fossile malheureusement il n'y a
pas d'avenir
il faut aller vraiment vers les énergies
renouvelables on n'a pas anticipé à léo
va revenir à nos municipal si ça vous
dérange pas donc general electric on
aura l'occasion d'en reparler
on fera des sujets dans le journal on
fera aussi des dimensions politiques sur
ce thème je connaîtrai faudrait une
petite note à monsieur ricard des ti
pour qu'ils puissent un peu mieux
connaître le dossier nous pourrons alors
nous étions nous étions sur la ville de
belfort
du coup votre parti le rassemblement
national arrive en tête avec plus de 22
% des voix vous allez présenter un
candidat
évidemment qu'on veut donner un candidat
qui parce que vous avez un turn over the
lancet vous ne présentez jamais les
mêmes candidats alors on n'arrivait pas
à fidéliser vos responsables politiques
en attendant si vous voulez bien je
trouve que les électeurs nous inquiète
pas tellement rigueur je vois qu'on fait
des scores confortable 22% à belfort
bien évidemment 10 % aux dernières
municipales vous inquiétez pas monsieur
damien meslot je pense que ça va être
votre épine dans le pied ça je suis pas
un souci je suis pense aussi on ne
présentera quelqu'un il ya plusieurs
personnes qui qui sont sur les rangs et
une commission nationale d'investiture
qui ce qui se prononcera dessus mais
soyez sans crainte vous aurez en face de
vous quelqu'un
monsieur la lumière est ce que compte
tenu du fait que vous êtes vraiment en
tête dans beaucoup d'endroits en franche
comté et je pense notamment au
département de la haute saône où vous
êtes en tête à vesoul et dans les villes
suivantes gré héricourt lure luxeuil
là vous êtes obligé de présenter vais
vous donner un scoop je vais vous donner
un scoop très très clairement dans le
choix des des communes où nous allons
nous positionner ont fait le choix nos
adversaires en fonction de nos
adversaires et les personnes si vous
voulez bien qu' on veut voir qu'on veut
voir partir c'est dire que c'est en
fonction de celui qui se présente à
droite à gauche voilà que vous c'est
votre stratégie voilà voilà
anna maillard vous pour europe ecologie
les verts est-ce que vous pensez que
vous arriverez à concrétiser donc
l'année prochaine dans 10 mois et
surtout hors 13%
quand on entend vos responsables
nationaux n'a l'impression qu'ils sont
arrivés en tête qui sont qui ce se qui
détiennent toutes les clés
scrutins futurs mais vous êtes trop fait
pour y aller seul
vous allez vous alliez à qui en veut je
pense qu'il est trop tôt pour parler
d'alliances et de partenariats
électoraux travaillant déjà sur un
projet mes amis de belfort mes amis du
pays de montbéliard
mes amis de besançon on est tous un peu
sur la même dynamique c'est à dire
voyons comment entendre ce que la
société a indiqué comme demande d'une
organisation écologiste de préparation
de ba d'anticiper de travailler sur
notre avenir commun travaillant sur des
plates formes de projets ils viendront
bien sûr des responsables politiques des
responsables à vous êtes en train d
aller comme un livre vous savez bien
qu'on a à faire à des femmes et des
hommes
chacun a son petit ego toc chacun veut
était justement c'était ma plus grande
surprise que moi je sais pas depuis si
longtemps en politique je viens du
mouvement associatif déjà des personnes
demandent attendait adjoint mr on va
s'organiser y aura une place pour tout
le monde non pour quel projet quand je
tombe sur un quart des tic idi on va
envoyer une personne face à l'autre mais
pour quel projet nous c'est ça qu'on
souhaite travailler
bien sûr je veux bien aux gestes si vous
voulez hein on n'est pas naïfs il y aura
bien deux personnes qui des personnes
avec de l'expérience politique ce seront
sans doute elle qui seront à peu dans
pourront peut-être le lead de ces listes
qui vont se constituer
mais travaillons collégialement avec des
entreprises avec des citoyens avec des
associatifs travail ont un projet et ce
projet on est persuadé qu'il entraînera
l'adhésion et ça veut pas dire qu'un
écologiste sera forcément tête de liste
nous on est capable d'avoir cette
humilité d'abord de comprendre le fait
qu' on a entendu des choses on est
arrivé au bon moment pour une société
qui en demande d'une réponse écologistes
non va la travailler collégialement en
avril a réponse à tout meilleurs envois
bande à l'évasion si ça vous dérange pas
on va parler de besançon
donc la république en marche arrivant en
tête avec 24% des voix
les écolos sont derrière à 18 6 en or
devant le ps place publique à 7,7 est
très très loin encore derrière on trouve
le pc avec 3%
alors oui je m'adresse à vous eric
alauzet dès lundi un communiqué a été
publié par nicolas baudens c'est le
candidat potentiel socialiste il appelle
à l'union de la gauche
et vous n'êtes pas du tout comptabilisés
dans cette gauche vous si vous perdez
cette étiquette de gauche jamais vous ne
pourrez gagner cette ville qui est
détenue par la gauche depuis plus de 60
ans vous allez avoir à marcher à
contre-courant
d'ici mars prochain on parlait de
nicolas baudin avec qui je suis dans la
majorité municipale actuellement avec
qui nous travaillons depuis cinq ans
nous partageons il a pas l'air dans la
gauche si nous avons voté quasiment même
tous les doutes tout ensemble
europe ecologie les verts est quasiment
les mêmes valeurs
bon voilà je vous laisse je vous laisse
apprécier ça que j'ai déclaré ma
candidature
oui que j'ai de nombreux soutiens oui et
que ça va peut-être pas sujet qu'elle
est que l'équipe savait le possiblement
la gauche devait les hanches et ne
veulent pas d'eux va voir le projet jeu
mais non mais ça se passe pas comme ça
là vous parlez des partis politiques il
faut il faut sortir de ces enfermement
des partis politiques adressez vous aux
bisontins tout au parc aux partis
politiques et vous verrez les choses
radical ça veut dire que vous pensez que
dans l'île sur les valeurs 6% des
électeurs d'europe écologie les verts
eelv on se moquer de l'appareil
politique ils vont voter je pense je
vois pas ce que ça fait trente ans que
je suis écologiste 30 ans chez les verts
notamment notamment que mes valeurs tout
le monde les connaît d'humanisme et
d'écologie des réalisations faites à
besançon je pense que les gens sont les
bisontins sont parfaitement au courant
de qui fait quoi et de qui de qui c'est
quoi ça m'a donc donc voilà c'est sur
les valeurs c'est sur le projet va faire
et veilleront au second plan oui ça
m'interpelle que monsieur alauzet par
l'écologie alors qu'il n'a réalisé par
le d'écologie alors qu'il l'a déserté
puisque maintenant vous travailler avec
un gouvernement qui quand il s'agit de
prendre des décisions écologique
ambitieuse n'y a plus personne
et moi ce qui me dérange aussi si vous
êtes député vous devez travailler un
projet pour la france
et là on a l'impression que c'était
juste une chambre d'attentes pour
ensuite vous présenter à la municipalité
de besançon qui est votre peut-être
votre grand projet il ya quelque chose
de dur à faire du monde erignac imerys
assez croquignolet ces querelles de
famille
gt gt ton frère avant tu étais ma soeur
avant mais maintenant je t' as - ouais
voilà ce pas on parlait donc dire relevé
que le gilet le nom tout sourit j'arrive
ne vous faites pas de soucis comme je me
mets pas ils ont pas la république en
marche vous avez comme la référente du
doubs alexandra kordic est par ailleurs
également chargé de la communication de
la ville qui est également sur les rangs
alors vous parlez pas d'états majors
politiques mais là vous en avez déjà
à résoudre c'est arrivé à récupérer
l'investiture lrm oui enfin franchement
je pense pas trop à ça je ne vois pas
d'ailleurs comment l'onu peut sembler
matin n'ont pas vraiment ce à quoi je
pense c'est l'avenir de ce territoire de
2020 à 2026 de la place de besançon dans
la grande région de delà du rôle de
besançon dans la transition énergétique
et écologique
ça ce sont des requestionner d'encre
occupe il faut savoir une question de
bonne volonté on a parlé en parlant de
question on a reçu une question de
d'auguste sur twitter voici ce qu'il dit
à l'oser est un trade qui se fait élire
avec une étiquette puis à changer de
paroisse par pur opportunisme et par pur
carriérisme vous avez 10 mois pour le
faire changer d'avis j'ai été élu sans
étiquette politique avec le soutien
d'aucun parti politique avec la
bienveillance du parti en marche
je remercie de m'avoir soutenue chez un
homme libre je suis un écologiste qui a
fait ses preuves que personne ne peut
remettre en cause et je veux travailler
dans un esprit d'ouverture d'accueil de
bienveillance sur sur ces transitions
nécessaires aujourd'hui on est face à
une menace sur le climat une menace face
à la biodiversité sur la classe de ce
territoire de la ville de besançon dans
la grande région c'est ça qui
m'intéresse
la tension à chacun et que aussi chacun
regarde un peu les autres et qu'on fasse
sens dans un esprit collectif
voilà ce qui m'intéresse un mot encore
sur cette question c'est vrai que les
plus quand monsieur à l'oser a pris des
décisions cave puis des positions qui
étaient écologistes vous étiez sheffield
depuis ce que j'ai vu l'opposition
écologiste c'est ça n'a pas trop vente
alala pas probante damien meslot vous
sur sur belfort on a vu la situation sur
besançon a priori les candidats de
droite ne se bousculent pas pour se
présenter
vous leur conseillez quoi de rester chez
eux et de laisser la gauche est la
république en marche se débrouiller il y
aura un candidat qui représentera la
majorité municipale bien évidemment mais
comme je vous l'aï dit nous ne sommes
pas dans les querelles que je viens
d'entendre entre tu as été un ancien
d'écologistes eut été ceci cela nous
nous sommes sur un projet de territoire
donc notre projet de territoire pour le
moment il est complètement sur le
problème de general electric
mais mes rêves je vous parlais de
besançon vous pensé pendant ces gamins
ça un symbole d'un mensonge ou par les
besoins urbains jeudi
à bourgogne franche comté ne se limite
pas à besançon il ya une querelle à
gauche au sein de la gauche
à besançon ce ne sont pas nos affaires
il y aura un candidat de la droite
républicaine à besançon alors dû sinon
par exemple de lons le saunier de lons
le saunier jacques pélissard donc des
républicains élus depuis 89 là la droite
voulait y aller en ordre dispersé parce
qu'elle se sentait imbattable l'as vu
les scores de dimanche ça va resserrer
les rangs je pense que aucune élection
n'est joué d'avancé que personne n'est
imbattable nulle part et qu'il faut se
rassembler et se rassembler sur des
projets municipaux ceux qui gagneront
les élections municipales sera pas ceux
qui auront telle ou telle étiquette ce
sera ceux qui auront un bon projet pour
leurs concitoyens
c'est cela les élections municipales et
les étiquettes politiques comptent
vraiment de moins en moins aux élections
municipales donc il faut avoir un bon
projet il faut être proche de ses
concitoyens et il faut proposer quelque
chose pour les six années du mandat
c'est là dessus que les électeurs sont
lassés richard des ti on a vu donc
belfort besançon lons à vesoul vous
arriver en tête c'est une première vous
avez envie de nuire on va dire ça comme
ça alain chrétien excellèrent maintenant
agir compatibles je pense que je pense
que je pense que la haute saône est une
terre fertile vous avez lu rossi 1 vous
avez monsieur éric houle et vous avez
vous avez exode de deux villes où on
fait des scores conséquent donc on fera
des choix et en fonction des vous aurez
assez de candidats parce que comme je
disais tout à l'heure vous avez du mal
quand même de fidéliser vos responsables
politiques on a peut-être du mal de
fidéliser nos responsables politiques
particulièrement ici en franche comté
est encore madame montel qui a été la
chef de fait pendant 30 ans qui
partageront la suite elle sera pas tête
de liste sur une commune n'en a besoin
ni ailleurs voilà si ce sera l'action
est là elle est partie aux patriotes
mannala quitter la vie politique
mais on voit quand même que vous
souffrez vous n'arrivez jamais à
présenter deux trois fois candidat
faites nous confiance vous verrez il y
aura des candidats dans les heures aux
endroits stratégiques et on n'en
déplaise à monsieur damien meslot ou à
la république en marche de monsieur à
l'oser ils feront des scores conséquent
parce que nous aussi nous avons des
projets pour les territoires ne sait pas
qu'il n'ya pas que vous qui avez des
projets pour l'étoile les territoires
qu'on nous en avant comme nous en avons
à la région où je suis lui
pour les élections de mars prochain est
ce que vous en ferez comme vous en avez
fait pour les européennes à référendum
pro ou anti macron mais nous on n'a rien
fait mais l'amnésie rice et monsieur le
président de la république en
l'occurrence macron qui a été visé le
débat et qui en a fait et il en a fait
un référendum macron stop ou encore
c'est pas du moins c'est pas nous on a
un projet européen qui étaient
conséquents avec avec des avec un bilan
et des projets voilà c'est le président
de la république a voulu briser on a
bien compris que c'est un débat européen
simplement il en a fait il en a fait un
pari qu'il a perdu en vendée en
combinaison est-ce que vous pensez que
dans 10 mois ces élections municipales
ce sera encore un référendum pro ou anti
macron où on passera vraiment à des
choses plus local
non ce sera ce sera le cas à la fin je
suis pas que le maire de belfort vient
ça vous arrange rapt est de deux voies
la république en marche si ça marche pas
bien au niveau national au niveau
français moi je sais pas on a tous nos
identités
on est tous plus ou moins impliqué sur
le territoire plus ou moins reconnus par
nos concitoyens pour le travail que
qu'on mène les valeurs qu'on peut avoir
donc l'ancrage il est excessivement
important et puis a quand même les
valeurs des références politiques ça ça
compte aussi
mais il ne faut pas d'enfermement
politique voilà et c'est je crois ce
qu'on écoute les français ont voulu dire
depuis des mois et des mois pas
seulement ces élections c'est écouter la
droite et la gauche
d'accord vous ne pensez pas la même
manière mais au moins discuter
correctement les uns avec les autres
arrêtez de vous taper dessus en
permanence de vouloir faire du dégagisme
ou de dire quand c'est la droite la
gauche c'est pas bien et inversement
ça il faut en sortir on a des valeurs on
peut être convaincu de ses valeurs mais
il faut respecter les autres essaient de
faire avec les où on allait vraiment
grave
il faut se mettre ensemble par exemple
que vous dites vous dites que vous
voulez être ouvert vous pouvez avoir du
modem avec vous sur votre liste l'année
prochaine mais on va pas raisonner en
termes de partis politiques on va
raisonner en termes de sensibilité et et
le modèle je dis juste que l'opposition
nous verrez à la gouverner à la
différence des élections précédentes
les personnes qui auront des étiquettes
politiques seront largement minoritaires
à les exclure quand même ce serait bien
anormal vu de travail qui est fait dans
les partis politiques mais seront
minoritaires
ella maillart comment vous voyez-vous à
europe ecologie les verts c'est ce grand
rendez-vous des municipales de l'année
prochaine je pense qu'il y aura la même
surprise qui a été pour ces élections
européennes ce qui va être connue
surtout sur les personnes qui seront sur
les listes
municipal ça va être leur engagement
précédent et on sait que chez les
écologistes on a des exemples concrets
de municipalités qui ont un projet
écologiste complet et qui fonctionne
grande synthe à la dont damien carême
qui vient de devenir d'épisodes dans
leur glace dans le nord d'eau contre
dunkerque tout contre dunkerque qui
montre qu'on peut
c'est des choses voudrait pas 56 et
quand même à d'examen grenoble mais
voilà qu'après c'est un peu il ya jean
macé bon c'est une petite ville de
burgos et la grande ville mais le
mouvement est en cours en fait on peut
pas être et avoir été ce que disait ma
grand mère là on est en train de devenir
et c'est très intéressant parce qu'il ya
des gens de haut niveau à chaque perso
moi je bénévoles dans des structures
d'insertion par l'activité économique
j'ai ma part les industries et condition
animale j'aime à ce que les écologistes
puisse aborder tous les sujets et là on
va pouvoir en faire la preuve pour ces
élections à venir qu'à chaque coup pour
chaque exécutif on a des candidats
solides
voilà deux dossiers qui vont devoir
retourner dans sa bile it et on en
reparlera mais damien meslot les
républiques à ça va être le grand
prochain rendez vous c'est elle en
parlait tout à l'heure du central grand
prochain rendez vous de tout le monde
will en particulier vous après des
présidentielle ratée après des
législatives chaotique des européennes
catastrophique
ça va être difficile peut-être savez je
sais que certains aimeraient voir des
difficultés pour les prochaines
municipales
nous verrons bien je pense que nous
avons beaucoup de maires qui ont réalisé
d'excellents mandat je pense que les
électeurs vont juger avant tout sur le
mandat et sur les perspectives sur le
projet que vous présenter nos élus
locaux et moi je pense que les
républicains et l'ensemble des maires
sortants qui se reconnaissent dans l'est
républicain ou d'en parler de tout à
l'heure à la chrétiens qui était chez
vous et maintenant agir c'est à dire une
faction d'une fraction donc le droit aux
pas que ce soit une facture je me suis
reprise qui qui qui est macron
compatible vous vous n'êtes pas macron
compatibles mais ce que vous avez peur
justement que ça ça prenne du poids à la
terre de la droite ces gens qui se
tourne vers mâcon écoutez nous verrons
bien moins en tout cas je ne je reste
fidèle à mes valeurs et au mouvement
gaulliste auquel j'ai toujours appartenu
maintenant chacun chacun fait ce qu'il
veut mais moi je pense que aux élections
municipales
les résultats sont très
différents des élections européennes
sature été autrement vous seriez battu à
belfort certains rêvent de me voir
vous savez entre le rêve et la réalité
il ya toujours un grand écart
merci beaucoup d'avoir participé à cette
émission merci madame merci messieurs
merci de votre attention et surtout bon
dimanche après midi à tous pour parle
bien sûr plus tard des élections
municipales au revoir
[Musique]